>> JAEL AND NATASHA LANDED IN
HOT WATER...
>> HIM MAD.
>> AAH! AAH!
>> AND MADE A BAD IMPRESSION
ON THEIR HIGH-POWERED GUESTS.
>> YOU DO NOT MESS WITH 50 CENT,
AND YOU DO NOT
GET THROWN INTO A POOL.
>> RENEE'S TOUGH EXTERIOR
WAS FINALLY WORN DOWN.
>> IS THAT TRUE?
Y'ALL DON'T LIKE ME EITHER?
>> YOU'VE BEEN NEGATIVE
TO EVERYBODY SO MANY TIMES.
IT'S LIKE,
HOW AM I GONNA BELIEVE YOU?
>> I'M SORRY
FOR ANYTHING I MIGHT HAVE SAID
TO OFFEND YOU GUYS.
>> AND WHILE SARAH
HAD EXPERIENCE
BEHIND THE CAMERA...
>> YOU'RE POSING AGAIN.
WANNA GO HOME THIS WEEK?
>> NO.
>> IT DIDN'T HELP HER
IN FRONT OF IT...
SARAH, THE JUDGES FEEL LIKE
YOUR PICTURES ARE POSED.
AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
SEVEN GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
>> YOU WANT TO BE ON TOP?
♪ ♪
>> IF SOMEBODY COULD'VE BET ME
MONEY
IF I WAS GONNA BE IN THE BOTTOM
TWO TONIGHT,
I WOULD'VE PROMISED YOU
I DIDN'T THINK THAT I WAS GONNA
BE IN THE BOTTOM TWO TONIGHT.
>> ONE MORE CHANCE, WHITNEY.
>> OH, MY LORD.
>> OH!
>> I HADN'T PERFORMED
TO THE BEST OF MY ABILITY.
THIS WEEK, I'M, YOU KNOW,
GOING INTO IT FULL THROTTLE.
(groans) IT'S SO HARD.
♪ ♪
>> I love you,
and me and Troy
both miss you very much.
>> MY HUSBAND
IS TRYING TO CHEER ME UP--
YOU KNOW, JUST BE HAPPY
AND WORK ON THE COMPETITION,
BUT I'M FEELING
REALLY DEPRESSED.
>> Troy, say hi to Mama...
>> APPARENTLY, I'VE DONE THINGS
THAT OFFEND THE GIRLS,
AND I DON'T MEAN FOR IT
TO OFFEND THE GIRLS.
I JUST NEED TO BE
A MORE SENSITIVE PERSON.
>> Troy's always up
running around,
and we miss you so much.
>> EVER SINCE WE HAD
THAT TALK WITH TYRA,
THINGS HAVE CHANGED.
>> SO YOU WERE HURT BY PEOPLE.
HURT PEOPLE HURT.
AND TO COPE, YOUR FUEL IS
TO HURT OTHER PEOPLE.
>> I'M SORRY
FOR ANYTHING I MIGHT HAVE SAID
TO HURT OR OFFEND YOU GUYS.
>> YOU'VE BEEN NEGATIVE
TO EVERYBODY SO MANY TIMES.
IT'S LIKE,
HOW AM I GONNA BELIEVE YOU?
>> ARE YOU MAKING HOT COCOA?
>> YES.
>> TRYING TO.
RENEE IS JUST HARD TO TRUST
AT THIS POINT.
I MEAN, I DON'T BELIEVE
ANYTHING THAT SHE SAYS.
>> RENEE WROTE ME A LETTER.
IT SAYS, "JAEL, I'M SORRY
FOR ALL THE WAYS I'VE HURT YOU
AND THE OTHER GIRLS."
RENEE APOLOGIZES TO ME
FOR EVERYONE
AND HOW SHE'S TREATED EVERYONE.
I KNOW THAT SHE'S AN ACTRESS
AND SHE CAN TURN IT ON OR OFF,
BUT THAT DOES NOT MEAN
SHE WASN'T GENUINE
IN HER APOLOGY.
I LOVE MY FRIENDS.
>> OH, MY GOD.
IT ITCHES SO MUCH!
>> IS ANYBODY HERE?
>> OH, MY GOD!
(screaming)
>> WHO'S HERE?
>> AN ANGEL. AN ANGEL CAME OVER.
>> CHRISTIAN, OUR HAIRSTYLIST,
COMES OVER TO OUR HOUSE
TO GET RID OF BRITTANY'S WEAVE.
>> IT'S REALLY BAD.
IT'S RIPPING OUT.
>> WELL, WE'LL HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT.
>> DAMN.
>> IT JUST ITCHES.
>> BRITTANY HAS BEEN COMPLAINING
AND BITCHIN' AND MOANIN'.
I MEAN, I'VE BEEN WEARING
A HAIR WEAVE
SINCE I WAS 12 YEARS OLD.
IT IS NOT THAT BAD...
>> OH, BOY.
>> POINT BLANK, BOTTOM LINE.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> THAT'S IT.
THAT...
>> THAT EVIL DISASTER OF A HAIR,
MY POSSESSED HAIR.
♪ ♪
>> TYRA MAIL!
"WHATEVER YOU DO,
DON'T BE YOURSELF."
>> WHAT DID IT SAY? SOMETHING
ABOUT
NOT BEING YOURSELF?
>> MM-HMM.
>> OOH!
>> (gasps) YES!
I CAN WIN A CHALLENGE!
I'M REALLY EXCITED
BECAUSE ACTING IS MY FORTE,
SO I THINK I'M GONNA
SHOW THE JUDGES
AND ALL THE OTHER GIRLS
THAT I AM A THREAT TO THIS
COMPETITION.
(laughs)
♪ ♪
>> MY HEAD FEELS
A MILLION TIMES BETTER.
I'M NOT GONNA BE IN PAIN
CONSTANTLY ANYMORE.
>> I REALLY ENJOY BEING HERE,
BUT IT IS VERY HARD FOR ME
BECAUSE I HAVEN'T SEEN MY BABY
FOR SO MANY WEEKS,
AND IT'S A REALLY BAD FEELING,
YOU KNOW?
(baby babbling over telephone)
>> GOSH, I WISH I COULD
TALK TO HER MORE.
THE HARDEST THING ABOUT BEING A
MODEL
IS BEING AWAY FROM MY BABY.
TA'KYA?
>> Daddy?
>> WHAT YOU DOING, BOO-BOO?
>> Hi, Mom.
>> (laughs)
NOTHING COMPARES TO MISSING YOUR
OWN CHILD.
THERE'S NOTHING LIKE THAT.
>> Okay.
>> (laughs)
>> Say, "Bye, Mommy."
>> Bye!
♪ ♪
>> WE ARRIVE ON THIS STREET,
AND WE WALK INTO THIS, LIKE,
THEATER SETUP.
IT KIND OF LOOKS LIKE
THE APOLLO THEATER A LITTLE BIT.
AND WHEN WE WERE STANDING THERE,
HERE COMES TIA MOWRY.
IS THAT TIA? IS THAT HER?
>> HEY!
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> TIA FROM...(singsongy)
"SISTER, SISTER"!
>> HI, LADIES. I'M TIA MOWRY.
I AM NOW ON A SHOW
CALLED "THE GAME"
THAT'S ON THE CW.
NOW AS A MODEL,
YOU GUYS ARE GONNA BE DOING
PHOTO SHOOTS, COMMERCIALS,
AND IT'S VERY, VERY IMPORTANT
THAT YOU GUYS ARE ABLE TO EMBODY
ALL DIFFERENT SORTS
OF CHARACTERS.
SO I'M HERE
TO BASICALLY TEACH YOU
HOW TO EVOKE
DIFFERENT CHARACTERS
THROUGH VOICE AND MOVEMENT.
FIRST, WHAT I WANT
YOU GUYS TO DO
IS TO CHOOSE A HAT.
GO AHEAD. (laughs)
>> (screaming)
>> AND WITH THAT HAT,
I WANT YOU GUYS
TO EMBODY THE CHARACTER.
I WANT YOU TO ACT LIKE
THE CHARACTER,
AND I WANT YOU TO TALK LIKE
THE CHARACTER.
>> (imitating old woman)
I DESERVE TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL!
UH-HUH!
>> OKAY, THAT WAS REALLY GOOD.
BUT WHAT I WANT YOU TO DO,
I WANT YOU
TO USE YOUR BODY MORE.
>> I DESERVE TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL!
(laughing evilly)
>> OKAY. YOUR TURN.
>> Y'ALL MAKE ME SO NERVOUS.
(laughs)
>> OKAY, DO YOU WANT ME
TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE ADVICE?
IT'S HOT OUTSIDE.
YOU KNOW, IN THE SOUTH
IT'S ALWAYS HOT.
>> (Southern accent) OH! ALABAMA
IS GON' LOVE ME AND THIS WALK!
>> (seductively) OOH,
I DESERVE TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> WHAT DOES A SEXY,
SEDUCTIVE WOMAN DO?
SHE TOUCHES HER LIPS.
SHE TOUCHES HER BODY.
SO THAT WAS EXCELLENT.
>> HELLO!
>> (laughs)
>> I THINK I DESERVE TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL!
(giggling)
>> PERFECT.
YOU WEREN'T AFRAID TO BE SILLY,
SO YOU DID AN EXCELLENT JOB.
>> I DESERVE TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
FOR I AM THE QUEEN OF THE WORLD.
(somber music playing)
>> (imitates crying)
I DON'T WANNA GO HOME NEXT WEEK.
(applause)
>> GOOD JOB.
(dance music playing)
>> (laughs)
>> I DESERVE TO BE AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL
'CAUSE THESE BITCHES ARE...
(cat meows)
>> (laughs)
>> AAH!
(applause)
>> THAT WAS REALLY, REALLY GOOD.
SO WHAT I HAVE FOR YOU GUYS
RIGHT NOW IS A SCRIPT.
AND YOU GUYS HAVE... TWO HOURS
TO MEMORIZE THE SCRIPT, OKAY?
>> YEAH!
>> ALL RIGHT, HERE ARE YOUR
SCRIPTS.
JUST REMEMBER TO JUST HAVE FUN.
>> OKAY.
>> ALL RIGHT. BYE!
>> YEAH!
>> OUR CHALLENGE TODAY
IS TO MEMORIZE THIS SCRIPT
IN TWO HOURS.
HOW THE HELL
WERE WE GOING TO DO THAT?
"IS THIS YOUR FIRST TIME
SHOWING IN NEW YORK?"
>> "MOST OF THE TIME,
DESIGNERS WAIT FOR ME."
>> "THIS IS SILLY."
>> THREE DIFFERENT CHARACTERS
TO GIVE THREE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
EMOTIONS.
>> THE FIRST ONE IS THIS
SENSITIVE GIRL.
>> MELODRAMATIC, BRITTANY-TYPE.
>> (whining) "BUT MOST OF
THE DESIGNERS, THEY USUALLY--
THEY WAIT FOR ME."
>> AND THEN THE SECOND ONE
WAS A DIVA-TYPE CHARACTER.
>> "MY RUNWAY SHOW
IS ABOUT TO BEGIN."
>> AND THEN THE NEXT ONE IS
THIS PERKY, BUBBLICIOUS MODEL.
>> "OH, THIS MUST BE
YOUR FIRST TIME
SHOWING IN NEW YORK,
'CAUSE IT'S ALWAYS LAME."
>> (laughs) IT'S PEDRO!
I'M THE FIRST PERSON TO SCREAM
OUT BECAUSE, I MEAN,
I WATCHED "NAPOLEON DYNAMITE"
SO MANY TIMES.
>> HELLO, LADIES.
>> HI.
>> I'M EFREN RAMIREZ.
YOU GUYS KNOW ME PROBABLY FROM,
UM, PEDRO
FROM "NAPOLEON DYNAMITE"...
OR SOMETHING.
I'M PRETTY MUCH KNOWN
AS A CHARACTER ACTOR,
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO PLAY
ALL THESE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
RANGES.
SO I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S
GONNA BE IMPORTANT FOR TODAY,
AND I'M GONNA TEST YOU GUYS OUT.
AT THE END,
I'M GONNA PICK A WINNER,
AND, UH, THAT WINNER
IS GONNA GET A SURPRISE, OKAY?
>> YEAH.
>> YEAH!
>> ON MY LIST I HAVE...
BRITTANY. YOU ARE FIRST.
>> YOU'RE LATE! YOU'RE LATE!
I GOT TWO MINUTES
BEFORE THE SHOW BEGINS.
>> (panting) THERE'S TRAFFIC
ALL UP AND DOWN
FIFTH AVENUE.
>> (Jamaican accent) I COULDN'T
DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT!
(normal voice) I HAVE NO IDEA
WHY THAT JAMAICAN ACCENT
CAME OUT,
BECAUSE I DO NOT
SPEAK JAMAICAN AT ALL.
(Jamaican accent) IS THIS
YOUR FIRST TIME DOING A FASHION
SHOW IN NEW YORK?
>> THERE WAS TRAFFIC
UP AND DOWN FIFTH AVENUE,
AND--AND I COULDN'T DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT!
(imitates sobbing)
>> RENEE STARTED OFF
WITH A BIG BANG.
SHE WAS FULLY COMMITTED.
OKAY, OKAY, WELL, LET'S GO!
LET'S HURRY UP, SHALL WE?
>> THE JUDGES TOLD ME LAST PANEL
THAT I NEEDED
TO REALLY STEP IT UP,
AND I THOUGHT, YOU KNOW WHAT?
NOW'S THE TIME TO SHOW
THAT I CAN DO THAT.
(imitating diva character) ALL
RIGHT, I'M A GIRL.
I GUESS I CAN DO MY OWN MAKEUP.
>> GO BEYOND THE LINES.
GO BEYOND THE--
>> AM I READY NOW?
>> I'LL PUT THIS ON...
MYSELF?
>> YOU DO KNOW HOW
TO PUT ON YOUR MAKEUP
YOURSELF,RIGHT?
>> UM...IT FELT LIKE
IT WAS NEVER GONNA END
ONCE I FORGOT MY LINES.
I FELT SO RETARDED.
>> JASLENE FORGOT THE LINES,
SO I THINK SHE WASN'T
FULLY COMMITTED WITH THE SCENE.
OKAY, THE SHOW'S ABOUT TO BEGIN,
AND WE'VE GOT TO DRESS YOU
RIGHT NOW.
HERE, PUT THIS ON.
>> (imitates perky character)
UM, THIS DRESS?
IT DIDN'T REALLY FIT ME LIKE
THIS
DURING THE FITTING, BUT, UM...
YOU KNOW WHAT? I'LL MAKE IT
WORK.
>> WHITNEY'S PERSONALITY,
FROM THE BEGINNING TO THE
END, WAS GREAT.
>> OH, YES!
OKAY, AM I READY TO GO?
>> YOU LOOK GOOD.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR YOU TO WALK.
>> AM I READY?
>> NOW GO!
>> I GUESS THIS IS WHAT IT'S
LIKE TO BE A TOP MODEL!
>> I GUESS THIS IS WHAT IT FEELS
LIKE TO BE A TOP MODEL.
>> OH, I GUESS THIS IS HOW
A TOP MODEL FEELS.
>> (laughing) I GUESS THAT'S HOW
IT FEELS TO BE A TOP MODEL!
>> (chuckles)
IT WAS TOUGH.
IT WAS REALLY TOUGH
TO PICK A WINNER.
I GOTTA SAY THERE WAS ONE
WHO WAS FULLY CONNECTED
TO WHAT SHE WAS DOING.
>> THERE'S PRESSURE ON ME
THIS TIME AROUND
BECAUSE I JUST HAVE TO WIN
THIS CHALLENGE.
>> SO TODAY'S WINNER...
IS RENEE.
>> YES!
>> YAY!
>> GOOD JOB.
>> I FINALLY WON ONE! (laughs)
>> YOU GET TO PICK A FRIEND,
ACTUALLY.
>> OH!
>> YEAH.
>> OKAY. UM, HMM...
DIONNE.
>> NO WAY!
>> YEAH!
>> AND I'M LIKE... (record
needle scratches)
>> ME?!
>> YOU SAID THAT YOU WEREN'T
GONNA GIVE ME
ANOTHER CHANCE, SO...
>> YOU'VE BEEN NEGATIVE
TO EVERYBODY SO MANY TIMES.
IT'S LIKE,
HOW AM I GONNA BELIEVE YOU?
(laughs)
GET OUT THE WAY!
I WAS LIKE, DAMN,
RENEE DON'T LIKE ME FOR REAL.
BUT THEN SHE'S TRYING
TO MAKE A CHANGE,
SO OKAY, I'M-A GO WITH THE FLOW.
>> DIONNE, YOU'RE EASILY BOUGHT.
(laughter)
>> WELL, APPARENTLY,
YOU GUYS GET A PRIZE.
YOU'RE GONNA LOVE IT.
>> (laughs)
>> THIS IS FOR YOU.
>> (gasps) WHAT THE...
>> AND THIS IS FOR YOU.
>> (laughs)
>> THEY GOT T-SHIRTS.
WE ARE ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP
MODEL,"
AND THESE FOOLS JUST GOT UP
THERE
AND GOT SOME DURN T-SHIRTS.
(laughs)
♪ ♪
>> A T-SHIRT? A T-SHIRT?!
WHAT YOU GONNA DO
WITH A T-SHIRT?!
THIS IS SO CUTE.
>> (snorts)
>> YAY!
>> LOOK AT THAT DAMN SMILE
ON YOUR DAMN FACE.
>> I'M JUST GRATEFUL
THAT I HAD WON A COMPETITION,
AND I'M VERY, VERY EXCITED
ABOUT MY T-SHIRT.
>> I'M REAL EXCITED FOR YOUR
LIFE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> RENEE IS JUST WALKING ALL
AROUND, JUST SMILING.
SHE'S REALLY BEEN TAKING
MAJOR, MAJOR STEPS
IN ORDER TO TRY TO BECOME
A BETTER PERSON.
>> GOOD.
(knock on door)
AND I SEE, LIKE,
THIS GROUP OF PEOPLE
IN THE FRONT.
>> GUYS!
>> WHAT THE HELL?!
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> (screaming)
♪ ♪
>> IS RENEE HERE?
>> WHAT THE HELL?!
>> RENEE, COME ON!
>> SO THE REAL PRIZE
FOR RENEE AND DIONNE
IS THAT THEIR FAMILIES
GET TO COME VISIT.
>> YOU ENJOYING
YOUR BATH, GIRL?
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> WHEN I SEE JASON AND TROY,
IT WAS AS IF I HAD NEVER LEFT.
OH, I HELD HIM,
AND HE STARTED GETTING
ALL EXCITED AND TALKING...
(kissing)
>> (cooing)
>> IT MADE ME FEEL REALLY GOOD
THAT HE REMEMBERED ME,
'CAUSE THAT WAS MY BIGGEST FEAR.
(laughs)
>> THIS MY GIRL.
>> THAT'S YOUR GIRL?
>> FIRST, MY EYES
HAVE GONE BLANK.
THEN FINALLY, I SEE MY MOM,
MY SISTER AND MY BABY.
AND THE FIRST THING
THAT CAME TO MY MIND IS,
WHAT THE... IS WRONG
WITH MY BABY'S HAIR?
I WAS SO PISSED,
'CAUSE MY OLDER SISTER--
SHE HAS ALL BOYS.
SO SHE DOES NOT KNOW
HOW TO DO HAIR.
SHE... MY BABY'S HAIR.
BUT I WAS PISSED
BUT I WAS GLAD TO SEE THEM.
>> THIS IS SO MUCH BETTER
THAN THE T-SHIRTS.
>> I KNOW, RIGHT?
>> I'M-A HAVE TO HAVE A TALK
WITH TYRA.
SHE GONNA HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT US OLDER WOMEN
IN WHEELCHAIRS OR SOMETHING.
>> WHEN I WAS 6 YEARS OLD,
MY MOM WAS SHOT BY THIS GUY.
HE WAS JEALOUS
THAT SHE WAS GETTING MARRIED,
AND SHE WAS ACTUALLY TRYING
TO HELP HIM GET OFF OF DRUGS,
AND HE ENDED UP SHOOTING HER.
THAT'S WHY MOM IS PARALYZED
TO THIS DAY.
>> COME ON.
>> YOU GOT IT?
>> TROY, MISS J. WOULD
HAVE YOUR HEAD ON A PLATTER
IF YOU WALKED LIKE THAT.
>> (laughs)
>> TROY IS THE LIGHT OF MY LIFE.
HE--HE'S JUST GOTTEN SO BIG
SINCE I'VE LAST SEEN HIM.
>> COME ON, BABE.
>> TYRA, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I REALLY, REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
>> POSE.
>> SEEING MY BABY HAS MADE ME
EXTRA HAPPIER.
YOU NEED A LITTLE INSPIRATION
EVERY NOW AND THEN,
AND THAT DID IT FOR ME.
SEE HOW PRETTY YOU LOOK. LOOK.
IT MADE ME FEEL SO GOOD INSIDE.
YOU HELPED ME!
(kisses)
YOU HELPED ME.
>> LOOK AT HOW BIG YOU GOT!
>> I'M REALLY HAPPY
FOR RENEE AND DIONNE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
AS A MOTHER,
I WAS MISSING MY BABY.
WITH MY MIND, I UNDERSTOOD
THAT THEY'RE WINNERS
OF THE CHALLENGE,
BUT I COULDN'T DEAL
WITH MY EMOTIONS.
YOU KNOW? AND I WAS LIKE...
>> Sorry, honey.
>> (sobbing)
>> BYE-BYE.
>> YOU READY?
THE HARDEST PART
WAS ACTUALLY SAYING GOOD-BYE
TO MY BABY,
BUT I'M HERE TO DO A JOB.
I'M HERE TO WIN
THIS COMPETITION.
I JUST GOTTA GET OVER IT.
(kisses)
COME ON.
THIS WAY.
>> I LOVE YOU.
MY REUNION WITH MY SON
AND MY HUSBAND
WAS SO MUCH BETTER
THAN I THOUGHT IT COULD BE
BECAUSE IT WAS SO UNEXPECTED.
>> (cooing)
>> IT WAS JUST
THE HAPPIEST DAY OF MY LIFE.
ALL RIGHT, TROY,
MOMMY LOVES YOU.
>> (cooing)
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> "ARE YOU READY TO BE SPOOKED
BY THE GHOSTS OF THE PAST?"
>> NO, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANS.
>> DID YOU SAY "GHOST"?
>> BY THE GHOSTS
OF THE PAST.
>> I HAVEN'T SLEPT ALL NIGHT
BECAUSE I WAS
THINKING ABOUT MY BABY,
AND ALL DAY'S GONNA BE BAD.
♪ ♪
>> I KNOW IT'S GETTING
TOUGH RIGHT NOW.
LOOK AT NATASHA.
SHE'S JUST NOT SMILING
THIS MORNING.
WELL, YOU GUYS
HAVE BEEN LEARNING
ALL ABOUT ACTING THIS WEEK
AND PORTRAYING CHARACTERS.
SO WE THOUGHT
FOR YOUR PHOTO SHOOT,
THERE'D BE NOTHING BETTER TO DO
THAN PORTRAY
SPECIFIC "INFAMOUS" CHARACTERS
FROM PAST CYCLES
OF "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
>> ALL RIGHT!
>> NOW PAYLESS ShoeSource
HAS SPONSORED MANY PHOTO SHOOTS
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
AND PAYLESS MAKES
SHOES AND ACCESSORIES
THAT'S REALLY ACCESSIBLE
FOR EVERYONE.
AND THEY HAVE A LOT
OF DESIGNER LINES THAT WE CAN
PULL FROM.
>> OH.
>> I CANNOT HIDE MY FEELINGS.
I CANNOT JUST PRETEND
THAT I-I DON'T FEEL ANYTHING.
OF COURSE, I'M VERY UPSET.
>> UNFORTUNATELY,
THIS IS A COMPETITION,
AND SOME GIRLS ARE GONNA HAVE,
YOU KNOW, PRIZE WINS
THAT OTHER GIRLS DON'T HAVE
AND STUFF LIKE THAT.
>> WELL, MR. JAY,
BUT MY EMOTIONS--I'M JUST...
>> BUT YOUR HEART HURTS?
>> YEAH. YEAH.
>> I HOPE THAT NATASHA
CAN PUT THOSE EMOTIONS ASIDE.
AS A MODEL, YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO WORK IN THIS PROFESSIONAL
ENVIRONMENT.
TRUST ME, AS--
WHEN TYRA HAS TRAVELED
ALL OVER THE WORLD,
SHE'S AWAY FROM HER FAMILY.
IT'S HARD, AND, LIKE,
I'M NOT GONNA LIE TO YOU.
IT'S NOT GONNA GET EASIER.
OKAY?
>> IT'S VERY HARD FOR ME TODAY,
BUT I'M GONNA
STAY IN THIS COMPETITION
BECAUSE I CANNOT JUST STOP
ON THE HALFWAY.
>> WELL, I HAVE A CLIP
SO YOU COULD
REFRESH YOUR MEMORY.
>> ONE OF THE GIRLS
GOT A FLESH-EATING BACTERIA
ON HER FACE.
>> (gasps)
>> OOH! IT'S--
WE'RE ALL GONNA DIE!
>> I LOOK... HORRIBLE.
>> WHY, HEY THERE!
>> OH, MY GOD!
(screaming)
>> SO BASICALLY,
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE MICHELLE,
AND MICHELLE IS GONNA BE
ONE OF THOSE GIRLS
THAT WEREN'T SO NICE.
>> (laughs)
>> THAT'S NICE.
THAT'S NICE THERE. BEAUTIFUL.
ROCK THOSE SHOES, DEAR.
ROCK THOSE SHOES. THAT'S NICE.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> THERE YA GO!
THAT'S THE SHOT!
>> THAT'S GREAT LIKE THAT
RIGHT THERE.
LOOK--THAT'S IT. THAT'S NICE.
>> LAST FRAME.
>> THANK YOU, LADIES.
>> OH, THOSE LAST COUPLE FRAMES
WERE GOOD.
>> YOU WERE TOTALLY AWARE
THAT YOU WERE SELLING SHOES
AT THE SAME TIME.
SO I WAS REALLY PROUD OF WHAT
NATASHA BROUGHT TO SET TODAY
IN TERMS OF ENERGY.
BECAUSE WHEN WE STARTED OUT
THE DAY,
NATASHA WAS VISIBLY UPSET,
BUT SHE WORKED LIKE
A PROFESSIONAL MODEL.
I'LL GIVE YOU A HUG FOR THAT.
>> AW!
>> THANK YOU! OH!
>> (laughs)
>> I HONESTLY KNOW
THAT MY PICTURES
AREN'T AS STRONG
AS THE OTHER GIRLS' PICTURES.
BUT I CAN'T BE HUNG UP
ON THE FACT THAT,
OH, I MIGHT GO HOME.
THIS PHOTO SHOOT,
I'M NOT GONNA OVERANALYZE IT.
I'M JUST GONNA WALK INTO IT
AND HAVE FUN.
>> OKAY, WELL, LET'S TAKE A LOOK
AT THE CLIP.
I'M GONNA BE WORKING WITH YOU
WITH MAKEUP, AND DIRECTING...
>> (laughs)
>> DON'T LAUGH AT ME.
AND YOU'RE POSING NUDE.
>> IF YOU DON'T STAND FOR
SOMETHING,
YOU WILL FALL FOR ANYTHING.
>> I NEVER WANNA POSE NUDE
NO MATTER HOW MUCH MONEY
OR HOW MUCH, YOU KNOW, FAME I
WOULD GET.
>> OH, GOD!
(laughs) AAH!
>> WHITNEY IS PLAYING THE SCENE
WHERE I WAS IN PARIS
AT THE BUDDHA-BAR,
AND I REFUSED TO POSE NUDE.
>> YOU'RE IN THIS SCENE
LIKE I'M ASKING YOU TO POSE
NUDE,
BUT SHE'S BASICALLY SAYING,
"UNH-UNH, GIRL,WE'RE NOT DOING
THIS."
>> I'M LIKE, NO!
>> AND DON'T GIVE ME "THE 80%."
I WANT THE 100% TODAY.
>> OKAY.
>> MM-HMM.
(camera shutter snapping)
>> GIVE ME A GREAT FACE.
ALL RIGHT.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE COMPETITION,
SO CHANGE THE EXPRESSION--
YOUR BODY, EVERYTHING. ALL RIGHT?
>> ALL RIGHT, GOT YOU.
>> SHE TRIED TO GIVE ME A GREAT
SHOT.
BUT I THINK IF SHE RELAXED
AND SPENT SOME MORE TIME
IN THE MIRROR,
IT'D BE BEAUTIFUL
BECAUSE SHE'S GOT A GREAT FACE.
(camera shutter snapping)
>> KEEP PLAYING. KEEP SHIFTING.
MOVE.
>> CHANGE IT AROUND.
>> CHANGE IT UP CHANGE IT UP.
YOU CAN ONLY BE ON "TOP MODEL"
ONE TIME.
EVERY DAY'S THE BEST DAY EVER.
>> OKAY, I'M GONNA SHOW YOU
WHAT HAPPENED.
>> YOU NEED TO WORK ON YOUR
PRESENCE.
I DIDN'T FEEL THAT YOU
EMBRACED--
(thud)
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> WHOA, SHE RULES.
>> HELP ME!
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> SOMEBODY CALL THE PARAMEDICS!
>> YES!
>> HI!
>> AWESOME!
>> HOW ARE YOU? I'M REBECCA.
>> HI.
>> JAEL, YOU ARE GONNA
BE REBECCA, LAYING DOWN, AND
REBECCA'S GONNA BE
HELPING YOU IN THE SHOT.
>> OH!
>> (laughs)
>> THERE WE GO.
WORK THOSE SHOES.
CHANGE THAT HAND UP THERE.
OOH! OOH!
>> SO, JAEL, NOT SO SEXY, OKAY?
SHE'S HELPING YOU.
JAEL--SHE DIDN'T ANALYZE
HERSELF.
THEREFORE, SHE JUST KIND OF WENT
ALL OVER THE PLACE,
AND SHE WAS GRABBING AT REBECCA.
THEY ALMOST LOOKED LIKE
THEY WERE LOVERS,
WHICH WAS NOT WHAT
THE SCENE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE.
PUT THAT OTHER HAND DOWN THEN.
MAYBE THAT'S PART OF IT.
YEAH.
REMEMBER, JAEL,
SHE'S NOT YOUR LONG-LOST LOVER.
>> I WAS ASKING FOR HELP.
>> UH-HUH.
>> RIGHT THERE.
>> LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT IT.
I'M GONNA SHOW IT TO YOU
ON THE TV SCREEN.
>> MICHELLE,
YOU ARE THE TOMBOY OF THE TWINS?
>> UH, YEAH, DEFINITELY.
>> SO IT LOOKS LIKE YOU GUYS
ARE JOINED BY THE--
>> IN THE HEAD.
>> IN THE HEAD, EXACTLY.
>> OKAY, THAT'S FINE.
>> HEY.
>> HELLO.
>> THIS IS MICHELLE
AND THIS IS AMANDA.
NOW YOU GIRLS
DID SIAMESE TWINS, RIGHT?
>> YEAH. NEVER DONE TRIPLETS.
>> SO WE'RE NOT DOING ANYTHING--
NEVER DONE TRIPLETS?
>> YEAH, NEVER DONE TRIPLETS.
>> TRIPLE ACTION HERE.
OH, THAT'S NICE. THAT'S NICE.
NICE THERE.
>> LOOK AT THAT ONE.
ISN'T THAT GORGEOUS?
>> YEAH, THERE WE ARE. THERE.
>> LAST FRAME.
>> LADIES, THAT WAS GREAT.
>> OUR THIRD SISTER, YOU KNOW,
SISTER FROM ANOTHER MISTER.
>> YEAH. SISTER FROM
ANOTHER MISTER.
JUST ALWAYS HAVE
A POSITIVE ATTITUDE,
AND THEY LOVE THAT.
>> DON'T SECOND-GUESS YOURSELF.
JUST GO FOR IT.
>> YEAH, HAVE YOU BEEN DOING
A LOT OF WORK?
>> I HAVE. YEAH, IT'S BEEN GOOD.
>> WHO ARE YOU WITH?
>> IN CHICAGO, I JUST SWITCHED
FROM FORD TO ELITE.
UM, OUT HERE, I'M WITH BLEU.
>> WOW.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE
THAT THESE PREVIOUS
"TOP MODEL" CONTESTANTS
MADE IT THE THROUGH THE STORM.
>> THAT'S JUST ME, THOUGH.
BUT, NO, I'M SURE
YOU'LL GET LOTS OF JOBS, TOO.
>> YOU'RE JOANIE, RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
>> YOU'RE GONNA BE IN THE...
>> IN THE DENTIST'S CHAIR.
>> IN THE DENTIST'S OFFICE.
>> WAS SHE REALLY PISSED OFF?
>> SHE WAS UPSET.
>> IN PAIN?
>> SHE WAS REALLY UPSET
AND IN PAIN, BUT AFTERWARDS
THEY WERE BEAUTIFUL.
>> COME ON.
I'LL SHOW YOU SOME FOOTAGE.
>> I'M SORRY, BUT THAT TOOTH...
(elephant trumpets)
>> THAT'S A PROBLEM.
>> WOW, DUDE!
>> (gasps) OH!
>> I'VE BEEN IN
THE DENTIST'S OFFICE
FOR 12 HOURS.
LOOK AT MY TEETH!
HEY!
>> HEY!
>> RENEE WAS POSING WITH JOANIE,
AND JOANIE WAS THE DENTIST,
AND RENEE WAS
IN THE DENTIST CHAIR,
AND IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
HER GETTING HER "NEW" TEETH.
>> THERE WE GO.
>> CAN WE DO ONE
WHERE SHE'S, LIKE, GOT THE TOOL,
LIKE, ALMOST IN MY MOUTH,
AND I'M MAKING
A REALLY PAINFUL FACE?
>> WELL, I STILL WANT YOU
TO LOOK PRETTY, RENEE.
>> I LIKE THAT, JOANIE.
THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
>> JOANIE ALMOST STOLE THE SHOW,
WHEN REALLY, RENEE NEEDED
TO POP IN THESE SHOTS.
>> MORE OF YOUR FACE.
DON'T HIDE IT SO MUCH WHERE...
>> OKAY.
>> WHERE I CAN'T SEE YOUR FACE.
>> THE JUDGES TOLD ME
I NEEDED TO UGLY IT UP.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOUR SHOTS ARE NOT PRETTY.
TRUST ME.
>> THE PERSON THAT
I HAVE TO PORTRAY IS KIM--
THE KISS IN THE LIMO.
AND I'M LIKE,
HOLD UP. I'M NOT NO... LESBO.
>> SO LET'S JUST TAKE A LOOK
AT WHAT HAPPENED.
>> I WANNA BE OUT.LIKE, I'M GAY,
AND I'M REALLY PROUD OF IT.
>> KIM, DO YOU THINK I'M
BEAUTIFUL?
>> YEAH.
>> OH, MY GOD. OH!
>> YEAH!
>> HOLY CRAP.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> COME ON! YEAH!
>> 1 DOWN, 11 TO GO!
>> (laughs)
>> THIS IS GONNA BE A CHALLENGE
FOR ME.
IT REALLY IS.
>> WHY?
>> IT LOOKS LIKE SHE'S KIND OF,
LIKE, KIND OF BOYISH,
KIND OF DORKY-LIKE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> BOYISH AND DORKY, HUH?
IT'S OKAY.
>> HI. IT'S NICE TO MEET YOU.
I'M DIONNE.
>> THIS IS DIONNE.
>> WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO GET A LOT
CLOSER
THAN THAT HANDSHAKE, YOU KNOW.
>> OH, IT'S NICE TO MEET YOU.
SEE, I'LL GIVE YOU A HUG,
BUT THAT KISSING...
I DON'T EVEN KISS
MY OWN DAMN BOYFRIEND.
>> ALL RIGHT. LET'S GO.
>> REMEMBER, SELL THE SHOES.
>> THIS IS SO CRAZY
AND UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> DIONNE, I WANT YOU
TO GET INTO IT.
REMEMBER, YOU'RE
PLAYING A CHARACTER.
I'M NOT ASKING YOU TO KISS HER.
THIS IS WHEN MY JOB BECOMES
REALLY DIFFICULT BECAUSE DIONNE
CLEARLY WAS NOT COMFORTABLE
WITH PORTRAYING A LESBIAN.
KEEP WORKING AROUND. ALL RIGHT.
>> STAY IN THAT MOMENT.
JUST BRING YOUR FACE
RIGHT BACK TO ME LIKE
YOU JUST GOT CAUGHT DOING IT.
>> THERE YA GO! THERE YA GO.
>> BEAUTIFUL. THERE.
(camera shutter snapping)
>> THERE YA GO, DIONNE!
>> RIGHT THERE.
>> (giggling)
>> WHY ARE YOU GIGGLING, DIONNE?
>> 'CAUSE I'M ACTUALLY
ENJOYING THIS.
>> UH-OH!
>> OH!
(laughter)
>> KIM, WHAT ARE YOU DOING
TO THESE GIRLS?
>> AND I HAVE NO IDEA
WHY I AM SO EXCITED
ABOUT BEING THIS CLOSE
TO A GIRL LIKE THAT,
AND I ACTUALLY FELT COMFORTABLE.
>> PERFECT.
>> IT WAS COOL. I ENJOYED IT.
>> ISN'T IT INTERESTING?
>> YEAH, THAT'S BETTER.
THAT'S IT. THAT'S IT.
>> LAST FRAME.
>> BEAUTIFUL.
>> GOOD.
>> OH. OH.
>> MATTHEW, THAT'S A WRAP.
>> WHOO!
>> (laughs)
>> LOOK AT HIM!
>> LOVELY.
>> (singsong voice) TYRA MAIL!
(normal voice) "TOMORROW, YOU WILL
MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY SIX WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
LOVE, TYRA."
IT'S BEEN TWO WEEKS IN A ROW
IN THE BOTTOM TWO,
AND I MADE IT THROUGH.
BUT THE PRESSURE IS ON
BIG-TIME--BIG-TIME.
>> THIS IS THE POINT
WHERE THAT'S IT.
THERE'S NO EXCUSE.
YOU HAVE TO BE
ON TOP OF YOUR GAME.
>> WE GOT SEVEN LEFT.
>> YEP.
>> WOULDN'T IT BE SO DOPE
IF WE WERE THE LAST THREE?
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> I DON'T THINK THE JUDGES
GET ME AT ALL BECAUSE, SEE,
I'M VERY COMPLICATED,
WILD AND CRAZY AND FREE
ALL THE TIME.
>> I'M SCARED.
YOU KNOW, LIKE, WHAT IF I BECOME
ONE OF THOSE GIRLS WHO--
OH, MY GOSH--
JUST STARTED SO GOOD AND THEN
SHE JUST STARTS FALLING?
YOU KNOW? LIKE... (groans)
THAT WILL HURT MY HEART.
♪ ♪
>> HELLO, LADIES.
>> HEY.
>> WELCOME BACK
TO THE JUDGING ROOM.
LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE
THE LUCKY SEVEN HERE TODAY.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, ONE OF YOU
IS GONNA GO HOME TONIGHT.
YOU KNOW ABOUT OUR PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
WITH ONE OF THE TOP
MODELING AGENCIES IN THE WORLD--
ELITE MODEL MANAGEMENT...
A 6-PAGE SPREAD AND A COVER
OF "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE...
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
LET ME INTRODUCE OUR JUDGES--
MR. NIGEL BARKER...
>> HOW YOU DOING?
>> MISS J. ALEXANDER,
RUNWAY DIVA COACH
EXTRAORDINAIRE.
AND HOW MANY RUFFLES
DO WE HAVE TODAY?
>> COUNT 'EM OUT, GIRL.
COUNT 'EM OUT.
>> UNO, DOS, TRES,
CUATRO, CINCO, SEIS, SIETE...
WHICH REPRESENTS
SEVEN GIRLS THAT HAVE LEFT.
>> MM-HMM.
>> AND FASHION ICON
AND LIVING LEGEND TWIGGY.
>> HELLO.
YOU ALL LOOK LOVELY TODAY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> AND OUR GUEST JUDGE,
A MAN THAT I LOVE VERY MUCH--
MR. MATTHEW JORDAN SMITH,
YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER
FOR YOUR PHOTO SHOOT
THAT YOU DID.
ALL RIGHT, SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
AND AFTER THAT,
THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE
AND WILL DETERMINE
WHICH OF YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED.
MISS WHITNEY, YOU ARE FIRST.
ALL RIGHT,
SO THE GIRLS HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE THEY HAD TO REENACT
VERY FAMOUS MOMENTS FROM
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL'S"
PAST.
>> MM-HMM.
>> AND WE GAVE YOUR PHOTOS
A COMIC BOOK STYLE THIS WEEK,
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW,
"TOP MODEL" CAN BE COMICAL
AT TIMES.
ALL RIGHT, WHITELLE,
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> "IF YOU DON'T STAND FOR
SOMETHING,
YOU'LL FALL FOR ANYTHING!"
>> MY GRANDMOTHER
USED TO ALWAYS TELL ME,
"IF YOU DON'T STAND FOR
SOMETHING,
YOU WILL FALL FOR ANYTHING."
>> (laughs)
>> YOU KNOW WHAT, WHITELLE?
I GOTTA TELL YOU,
AS THEATRICAL AS YOU ARE,
YOU SHOW YOUR EMOTIONS
ON YOUR FACE... I DON'T QUITE
GET THAT SAME PASSION
IN THIS PICTURE.
>> I AGREE.
IT'S KIND OF SLIGHTLY DEAD.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT'S ALIVE,
KIND OF PROTESTING SHOT.
>> I'VE GOTTA AGREE ALL THE WAY
BECAUSE WHEN YOU WALKED OUT HERE
JUST NOW, I'M LIKE, WOW.
ALL THAT PERSONALITY
AND GOING THROUGH
ALL THIS ENERGY...
I DIDN'T SEE THAT YESTERDAY
AT ALL.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK HAPPENS TO
YOU ON SET?
WHY DO YOU THINK YOU LOSE IT?
>> I THOUGHT THAT I HAD
A LOT OF ENERGY,
AND IN THE PAST COUPLE
OF PHOTO SHOOTS,
I'VE JUST BEEN TRYING
TO GO OUT THERE AND JUST GO OUT
AND HAVE A GOOD TIME.
SO IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT
THAT WASN'T PORTRAYED
THROUGH MY FILM,
BUT I REALLY THOUGHT THAT,
YOU KNOW, I GAVE IT ALL I HAD.
>> LET'S SEE A CLOSE-UP.
I THOUGHT YOU DID A GOOD JOB
WITH THE ACTING PORTION OF IT--
THE SILENT MOVIE ACTRESS,
WHICH MODELS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE.
UNFORTUNATELY,
THEY DIDN'T LOOK AS MODEL-Y
AS WE WOULD HAVE LIKED.
JUST WASN'T SELLING
WHAT THE SHOOT WAS ABOUT.
ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS BRITTANY.
>> HELLO.
WEAVE-LESS, LOOKING SO CUTE.
>> NOW IT FEELS SO MUCH BETTER!
>> ALL RIGHT, SO LET'S SEE
YOUR BEST TRIPLET SHOT.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> MISS BRITTANY IS SAYING,
"GOOD THINGS
ALWAYS COME IN THREES!"
(laughter)
>> THAT'S A GREAT PHOTOGRAPH.
>> YOU LOOK GORGEOUS
IN BETWEEN THESE TWO GIRLS.
AND THOSE TWO GIRLS
BOTH PHOTOGRAPH EXTREMELY WELL.
SO FOR YOU TO STAND
IN BETWEEN THE TWO OF THEM
AND ACTUALLY SHINE,
I--THAT'S IMPRESSIVE.
>> I'D LOVE TO SEE A CLOSE-UP.
YOU CONTACT WITH THE LENS,
AND SO IT JUMPS OFF THE PAGE.
>> ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
THE TWINS STAYED AROUND SO LONG
IS THEY HAVE AN AWKWARDNESS
THAT WORKS IN THE FASHION WORLD,
AND YOU POSED
TO MATCH THEIR AWKWARDNESS.
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU, BRITTANY.
ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS JASLENE.
SO, JASLENE,
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> OOH, MISS JASLENE IS SAYING,
"I DIDN'T STEAL
YOUR GRANOLA BAR, BEE-YOTCH!"
(laughter)
>> YOU REALLY JUST NEED
TO BREAK OUT YOUR BODY
A LITTLE BIT...
>> SOFTEN IT UP.
>> AND SOFTEN IT UP.
>> YEAH.
>> I STILL FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE NOT GETTING STRONG IN THE
COMPETITION.
YOU'RE GETTING WEAKER.
IT WENT FROM TOO STRONG,
PROBABLY A LITTLE DRAG-Y,
TO TOO WEAK AND KIND OF BORING.
IT'S LIKE YOU COULDN'T REALLY
FIND YOUR FOOTING.
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> UP NEXT IS NATASHA.
SO, NATASHA, HERE'S YOUR BEST
SHOT.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> (Russian accent) "I MAKE
FLESH-EATING BACTERIA LOOK
FIERCE!"
(normal voice) YOU DO, NATASHA.
>> OH, MY GOD.
(laughter)
>> WELL, CONSIDERING
YOU'RE COVERED
IN HORRENDOUS BLEMISHES,
YOU LOOK EXTRAORDINARY.
>> NATA, I THINK YOU'VE ACTUALLY
REALLY BEGINNING TO LEARN
HOW TO MODEL, AND IT'S SHOWING
IN YOUR PICTURES.
>> YES.
>> THE GOOD THING ABOUT YOU
IS YOU GET A NOTE AND YOU
CORRECT IT.
I TOLD YOU TO MAKE IT FEEL LIKE
YOUR MOUTH WAS AT THE DENTIST,
'CAUSE YOU DO LIKE THIS
ALL THE TIME IN YOUR PICTURES.
YOU RELAXED YOUR MOUTH,
WHICH MADE YOU HAVE
75% MORE PICTURES
TO CHOOSE FROM.
YOU ARE REALLY STEPPING UP.
>> I GOTTA TELL YOU.
I MEAN, SHE WALKED IN
YESTERDAY MORNING,
AND SHE WAS A LITTLE DOWN.
I'M LIKE, WOW, OKAY,
IT'S GONNA BE A HARD TIME
GETTING A SHOT FROM YOU.
AND THEN YOU CAME OUT FOR THE
PHOTO SHOOT,
AND YOU HAD THIS NEW ENERGY,
AND YOU GAVE US THE SHOT.
>> IT'S A REALLY BEAUTIFUL
PICTURE.
IT'S GREAT,MINUS A FEW BUMPS
AND...
(laughter)
>> ALL RIGHT, NATASHA,THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> UP NEXT IS DIONNE.
ALL RIGHT, WELL,
YOU LOOK A LITTLE...
(record needle scratches)
>> DUMPY THIS WEEK.
>> I DO?!
>> (singsong voice) YEAH, GIRL.
>> (laughs)
>> I THOUGHT I HAD IT TOGETHER.
>> I THINK IT'S TOO MUCH FABRIC
GOING ON. THERE YA GO.
>> JUST PULL IT BACK.
I'LL HOLD IT THEN.
>> OH, MY GOD. LOOK.
>> OH, TYRA, YOU'RE SO CLEVER.
>> DIONNE, YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU...
>> I HAD TO REENACT THE SCENE
WHERE SARAH AND KIM KISSED.
AND I WAS SO SCARED,
I'M GONNA STRAIGHT UP TELL YOU.
>> BUT WHY WERE YOU SCURRED?
>> 'CAUSE I'VE NEVER
KISSED A GIRL BEFORE.
I-I ONLY PUT MY LIPS ON MEN.
>> (laughs)
>> I JUST FELT UNCOMFORTABLE.
THAT'S ALL I CAN SAY ABOUT IT.
>> THAT'S 'CAUSE YOU SCURRED
'CAUSE YOU KNOW
YOU WOULD LIKE IT.
>> WHAT?!
(laughter)
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> LET'S SEE YOUR SHOT.
OH, THIS IS KIM'S
"ONE DOWN, ELEVEN TO GO!"
>> ONE DOWN, ELEVEN TO GO!
(laughter)
>> CONSIDERING YOU FELT
SO UNCOMFORTABLE,
I THINK IT'S A FABULOUS PICTURE.
>> AND YOU LOOK LIKE
YOU DIDN'T WANT THAT TO HAPPEN.
>> MM-HMM.
>> YOU CAME OUT
AND YOU BECAME
MY FAVORITE GIRL OF THE DAY.
>> (laughs)
>> ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS JAEL.
ALL RIGHT, JAEL,
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> "I GUESS I AM
DROP DEAD GORGEOUS!"
FOR SOME REASON,
YOU COULDN'T LET GO
AND LOOK FAINT-Y.
YOU WERE VERY, VERY POSE-Y.
>> YOU'RE NATURALLY
SORT OF ROBOTIC
IN THE WAY YOU MOVE,
SORT OF LIKE...
AGAIN, AGAIN.
YOU KNOW?
AND I THINK--
AND YOU JUST NEED TO LET GO.
>> WELL, I WAS TAKING DIRECTION
FROM JAY AS WELL.
LIKE, HE DID--
HE TOLD ME TO, LIKE...
(whimsical music playing)
>> YOU KNOW?
'CAUSE I WAS, LIKE--
WHAT I STARTED OFF AS, LIKE,
AS I WAS IMAGINING THAT, LIKE,
YOU KNOW, I WAS GONNA BE
LOOKING UP AT HER,
'CAUSE HE SHOWED ME THE VIDEO
AND EVERYTHING,
AND HE TOLD ME TO COME ALIVE
AND, LIKE, SELL THE SHOES.
YEAH.
(sighs)
>> ALL RIGHT, JAEL, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> LAST BUT NOT LEAST, RENEE.
YOU, UM, WON THE CHALLENGE.
>> YES, I DID.
THAT WAS AMAZING,
TO SEE MY FAMILY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
ALL RIGHT,
SO LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> LOOKS LIKE JOANIE'S SAYING,
"IT HURTS--DON'T IT?"
(laughter)
>> YUMMY.
>> IT'S GOOD.
AND YOU STILL LOOK PRETTY.IT'S
GREAT.
YOU'RE FROWNING
AND YOU LOOK IN PAIN,
BUT YOU STILL LOOK PRETTY.
>> THE LAST PANEL,
YOU GUYS TOLD ME TO UGLY IT UP.
SO I-I REALLY TRIED THIS TIME
NOT TO WORRY ABOUT
WHAT MY FACE LOOKED LIKE,
AND JUST GO FOR
THE "I'M SCARED," YOU KNOW?
>> WE TOLD YOU TO UGLY IT UP,
BUT NOW... JUST NOT SO UGLY.
>> OKAY. (laughs)
>> REMEMBER, MAKE IT UGLY...
AND PULL IT BACK.
>> IF YOU'RE GONNA GET
ANY BETTER AT IT
AND YOU'RE GONNA IMPROVE--
THE HAIR, THE MAKEUP,
IT'S ALL TOO MUCH.
IT DOES MAKE YOU LOOK
A LITTLE OLDER.
>> YEAH, IT'S A BIT TOO POUFED
UP.
>> OKAY.
>> ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE "TOP MODEL" HISTORY.
♪ ♪
>> (Cockney accent) NOW IT'S
TIME TO DECIDE WHO'S GOING HOME.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> (normal voice) DIONNE, A.K.A.
BROWN.
>> WELL, I THINK SHE'S JUMPING
UP LEAPS AND BOUNDS.
IT'S LOVELY TO SEE HER GROW LIKE
THAT.
>> SHE LOOKS AMAZING.
GREAT BODY LANGUAGE.
SHE LOOKS SEXY
TO A MAN OR A WOMAN.
THAT'S WHAT THE SECRET OF
MODELING IS.
>> SHE WALKED INTO THIS LIMO,
AND SHE WORE IT OUT.
I THINK SHE'S AMAZING.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> RENEE.
>> I DO LOVE RENEE.
I-I THINK SHE'S GOT SOMETHING
RATHER SPECIAL.
>> THE ONLY PROBLEM
THAT I HAVE WITH HER
IS THAT IT DOESN'T TAKE MUCH
TO MAKE HER LOOK OLDER.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> WHITNEY.
>> SHE'S GOT
A GREAT PERSONALITY.
SHE'S A VERY CLEVER GIRL.
>> OOH.
>> I-I JUST DON'T THINK SHE'S A
MODEL.
>> SHE'S ONE OF THOSE GIRLS
WHERE YOU LOOK AT THEM,
AND THEY'RE SO BEAUTIFUL,
AND THEN SOON AS YOU
LIFT THE CAMERA, THEY GO...
>> (laughs)
>> THAT'S ACTUALLY QUITE COMMON.
IT'S EXTRAORDINARY.
YOU LIFT THAT LENS UP,
AND THE WHOLE THING JUST GOES...
AND YOU'RE LIKE, WHOA.
YOU PUT THE CAMERA DOWN,
AND IT'S LIKE...
(hums)
I KNOW. EXACTLY.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> (singsong voice) JASLENE.
>> SOME GIRLS, YOU GOTTA DRAG IT
OUT,
AND OTHER GIRLS, IT'S JUST DRAG.
>> (laughs)
(camera shutter snaps)
>> (imitates Jael) JAEL.
>> WHEN SHE OPENS HER MOUTH,
IT MAKES ME CRAZY.
>> (imitates Jael) I DON'T THINK
YOU'RE BEING FAIR.
LIKE, OKAY...
>> (laughs)
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE SHE'D GET
THROUGH ANY CASTING,
UNLESS SHE DIDN'T HAVE TO SPEAK.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU GUYS
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
SHE'S A LITTLE ROBOTIC,
BUT THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT HER.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> NATASHA.
>> SHE'S REALLY PROGRESSED.
I'M VERY IMPRESSED WITH HER.
>> I THINK THIS GIRL
IS GORGEOUS.
I THINK SHE'S SEXY.
I THINK SHE'S VERY SPECIAL.
>> I STILL SEE HER PRESENCE
AS A BIT PACKAGED.
>> HI!
>> (imitates Natasha) THANK YOU.
I WILL TRY TO DO THAT.
(camera shutter snaps)
>> BRITTANY.
>> HERE SHE IS, RIGHT IN BETWEEN
A COUPLE OF MY FAVORITE GIRLS
IN THIS COMPETITION,
AND SHE'S REALLY STANDING OUT.
>> YES.
>> A TOP MODEL OR A SUPERMODEL
TENDS TO HAVE THAT KIND OF
FEELING.
THEY WALK INTO A ROOM--
EVERYTHING STOPS.
>> I NEVER UNDERSTOOD WHY
I WOULD TURN AROUND AND SEE
THESE PEOPLE LAYING ON
THE GROUND WHEN I WALKED BY.
NOW IT MAKES SENSE.
>> NOW YOU KNOW.
>> (laughs) OH! OH!
>> LORD, I'M JUST
KILLING THE FOLKS OUT THERE.
♪ ♪
>> SEVEN BEAUTIFUL YOUNG LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE SIX PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS.
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE GIRLS THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS
BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
FIRST NAME THAT I'M GOING TO
CALL...
DIONNE.
YOU'RE STARTING TO BECOME
WHAT THIS COMPETITION
IS ALL ABOUT--
TURNING INTO A TRUE MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME. (laughs)
>> THE NEXT NAME THAT I'M GONNA
CALL...
NATASHA.
>> (speaks Russian)
>> WHAT DID YOU JUST SAY?
>> "OH, MY GOD."
>> YOU'RE GETTING
BETTER AND BETTER EVERY WEEK,
EVEN WITH A FACE ALL BROKEN OUT.
YOU'RE REALLY LEARNING
AND UNDERSTANDING
WHAT THIS INDUSTRY IS ALL ABOUT.
KEEP UP THE GOOD WORK.
>> (in Russian) THANK YOU, TYRA.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
BRITTANY.
TO BE, LIKE, THAT TOP GIRL
THAT EVERY LITTLE GIRL
WANTS TO BE LIKE IN AMERICA,
YOU GOTTA HAVE
A PHYSICAL PRESENCE
THAT'S STRONGER.
SO WORK WITH THAT HAIR.
PUT A LITTLE GEL IN IT,
SLICK IT BACK,
JUST SOMETHING
TO KINDA MAKE YOU SHINE
MORE THAN YOU ALREADY DO.
>> OKAY.
>> CONGRATULATIONS, BRITTANY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> RENEE.
FIGURE OUT HOW TO MAKE IT
"PRETTY" UGLY, NOT JUST UGLY.
>> (laughs) ALL RIGHT.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> NEXT NAME I'M GONNA CALL...
JASLENE.
>> YOU'RE JUST FALLING AND
FALLING.
WHERE'S THAT GIRL THAT USED TO
BE CALLED FIRST EVERY WEEK?
WE WANNA SEE HER.
>> THANK YOU, TYRA.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
WILL JAEL AND WHITNEY
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
>> HMM.
>> (sighs)
>> I HAVE ONE PHOTO IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS
BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND I'LL CALL ONLY ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY RETURN TO THE
HOUSE,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS AND GO
HOME.
YOU GUYS ARE HOLDING ON
TO EACH OTHER
AND SHOULD HOLD ON TO EACH OTHER
FOR DEAR LIFE,
BECAUSE YOU EACH HAVE
WHAT THE OTHER PERSON NEEDS.
WHITNEY, YOU NEED TO SHINE
IN A PICTURE,
NOT JUST BE BEAUTIFUL IN PERSON.
A TOP MODEL
CAN'T JUST BE INTELLIGENT.
SHE'S GOT TO TAKE
A GREAT PICTURE AND THEN GO,
OH, WAIT, I'M SMART, TOO.
AND, JAEL, YOU NEED TO LEARN
TO SPEAK WITH AN ELOQUENCE,
LIKE WHITNEY.
A TOP MODEL CAN'T JUST BE PRETTY
AND TAKE A PRETTY PICTURE.
SHE'S GOTTA BE ABLE
TO SELL PRODUCTS, DO INTERVIEWS
AND HAVE DAVID LETTERMAN
AND DIANE SAWYER,
AND EVEN TYRA SOMETIMES,
INTERVIEW YOU
AND BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE HECK YOU'RE SAYING.
>> JAEL.
♪ ♪
>> (whispering indistinctly)
>> CONGRATULATIONS, JAEL.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU, TYRA.
>> SAY SOMETHING TO ME
THAT YOU MEAN AND FEEL RIGHT NOW
THAT IS SO CLEAR AND ELOQUENT
TO PROVE
TO THESE PEOPLE BEHIND ME
THAT YOU CAN SPEAK.
>> I WILL DEFINITELY
PROVE MYSELF TO BE
ALL THAT YOU BELIEVE I AM.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OH.
(blows kiss)
>> CAME A LONG WAY,
MISS LADY, DIDN'T YA?
>> YES.
YOU CAME A LONG WAY, AND I THINK
YOU LEARNED A LOT HERE.
>> I HAVE.
>> GOOD.
>> THIS ISN'T THE LAST.
>> IT ISN'T THE LAST.
>> WE'LL MEET AGAIN.
>> OKAY, YOU NEED TO GO HOME AND
PRACTICE AND STUDY,
BECAUSE YOU DON'T WANT TO WASTE
ALL THIS GREATNESS.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU GOT THIS AND YOU GOT
THIS,SO WORK BOTH OF 'EM.
>> (whispers) GOT YOU.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> ALL RIGHT, LADIES. OH. OH.
I LOVE YOU, GIRLS. MWAH.
>> OH, YOU ARE AMAZING.
>> BYE.
>> I HONESTLY DID NOT THINK
THAT I WAS GONNA
BE ELIMINATED TODAY.
OF COURSE I'M DISAPPOINTED
THAT I'M NOT
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I WANTED TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
AND ANY GIRL
WHO GETS UP HERE AND SAYS,
"OH, NO, I DON'T CARE,"
THEY'RE LYING.
YOU KNOW,
IT'S BECOMING EVIDENT TO ME
THAT MAYBE MODELING
ISN'T EXACTLY THE AVENUE
THAT I NEED TO BE GOING DOWN.
BUT TYRA BANKS
TOLD ME THAT I'M AN ACTRESS.
SO YOU KNOW WHAT?
DAMN IT, I'M-A TRY IT. (laughs)
♪ ♪
>> COMING UP ON "AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL,"
THE GIRLS ATTEMPT TO GAIN
SOME INTERVIEW SKILLS...
>> YOU FEEL LIKE YOU DESERVE TO
BE HERE?
>> HELL, YEAH, I FEEL LIKE I
DESERVE TO BE HERE.
>> WELL, YOU HAVEN'T WON
THE CONTEST YET, SO...
>> ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT, ALL
RIGHT.
>> THIS INTERVIEW'S GETTING A
LITTLE HOT! (laughs)
>> WHOO!
>> THEN GET READY TO TRAVEL THE
GLOBE.
>> (screaming)